Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
È il 2000,
e il leggendario programmatore
della Silicon Valley Bill Joy
scrive un editoriale su Wired
dal titolo abbastanza eloquente:
"Il futuro non ha bisogno di noi".
L'argomento di Joy è molto semplice:
se continuiamo a migliorare
la nostra capacità
di costruire macchine
che eseguono compiti complessi,
siamo molto vicini
a inventare l'ultima macchina:
la macchina che renderà tutti noi
superflui e obsoleti.
Avanti 20 anni:
2019, tutta la stampa
della Silicon Valley, da cui provengo,
sta tentando di convincervi ogni giorno
che siamo vicinissimi a un mondo
in cui la profezia di Joy
si sta avverando.
La cosiddetta quarta
rivoluzione industriale,
quella dell'AI,
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
delle macchine pensanti.
Io sono Jacopo,
sono il fondatore di una start-up
che si chiama Tooso, o oggi Toso,
con altre due persone -
molto più serie di me, evidentemente.
Vivo a San Francisco,
e mi occupo di intelligenza artificiale.
Ho accettato l'invito
a questo talk, principalmente,
per spiegare ai miei genitori
cosa faccio tutto il tempo
dall'altra parte dell'oceano.
(Risate)
AI, San Francisco, Silicon Valley:
io sono, sulla carta, la persona perfetta
per venire a convincervi
del verbo che viene dalla California;
ma se vi aspettate un talk
da Silicon Valley,
oggi rimarrete profondamente delusi.
La verità è che non vi biasimo
se avete un po' creduto
a tutta questa retorica
delle macchine pensanti.
Negli ultimi anni,
l'intelligenza artificiale
ha raggiunto risultati straordinari,
riuscendo a fare cose che prima
erano considerate tipicamente umane,
come ad esempio riconoscere
gattini su YouTube -
che è un'attività che so
che a tutti voi sta molto a cuore -
e, un po' più seriamente,
a battere il campione mondiale di Go.
Go è una specie di versione cinese,
e molto complicata, degli scacchi.
Il campione mondiale di Go,
come si vede nella foto,
non era particolarmente contento
dell'esito della partita.
L'Intelligenza Artificale attuale
progredisce, principalmente,
per quelle che vengono
chiamate "reti neurali",
che sono di solito rappresentate
con questi vaghi schemi
in cui ci sono dei "neuroni"
e delle connessioni,
da cui il nome rete neurale:
questa vaga ispirazione al cervello umano.
Quel che succede è che voi date in pasto
un input a questa rete, che lo processa -
come l'immagine di un gatto -
e vi dice cosa c'è su queste immagini:
ad esempio, un gatto.
La verità è che per capire
dove la Silicon Valley si sbaglia,
non serve sapere davvero
cos'è una rete neurale,
o tutte le formule
che spiegano come funziona.
In particolare, vorrei che vi dimenticaste
qualsiasi cosa sappiate
sulle reti neurali, tanto o poco:
pensate per oggi alle reti neurali
come una scatola magica.
Sono una scatola che inizialmente
è completamente vuota,
a cui voi date immagini
di cani e gatti, una dopo l'altra.
Ogni volta che mettete un'immagine
in questa scatola magica,
dite: "Questo è un cane"
o "Questo è un gatto".
La scatola è magica perché,
dopo che voi fate questa cosa
100.000 volte, o dieci milioni di volte,
la scatola effettivamente, da sola,
sarà in grado di distinguere
cosa è un cane e cos'è un gatto.
Quello che però non vi dicono,
sulle copertine patinate
di Wired o di Time Magazine,
è quanto costa imparare
cos'è un gatto su YouTube.
Imparare cos'è un gatto su YouTube
ha richiesto 16.000 processori
e l'equivalente di 10 milioni di gattini,
che sono veramente tanti gattini.
Battere un essere umano a Go
ha richiesto cinque milioni di partite,
ovvero l'equivalente
di 500 anni umani di gioco.
Il solo costo di elettricità, per Google,
di programmare quel computer
è stimato in termini
di 25 milioni di dollari.
Quindi, la prossima volta che vi lamentate
della vostra bolletta elettrica,
pensate a quella di Google.
È un'idea abbastanza intuitiva, in realtà,
che anche noi abbiamo
nella vita di tutti i giorni:
se io domani vado a Monaco,
due giorni [dopo] torno
e parlo tedesco perfettamente,
voi tutti sarete ammirati
dalla mia capacità di imparare,
penserete che io sia un genio.
Se vado in Germania 40 anni,
sposo una tedesca,
lavoro in un'azienda tedesca, faccio figli
in Germania, torno e parlo tedesco,
questa cosa è ovviamente
molto utile, praticamente,
ma nessuno penserà
che per questa cosa io sia un genio.
Quello che succede,
quando la Silicon Valley vuole convincervi
che il mondo di Bill Joy
sta arrivando ed è alle porte,
è che lo slittamento
tra il concetto di intelligenza
e apprendimento che usiamo per noi umani
e quello che usiamo per le macchine
è profondamente diverso.
Ed è in questo slittamento,
che sta fondamentalmente l'inganno.
Facciamo un esperimento - purtroppo,
non ho niente da farvi cantare.
Non so quanti di voi abbiano visto o meno,
in vita vostra, un Aardvark.
Alziamo la mano:
quanti hanno visto un Aardvark?
Nessuno. Oh, qualcuno!
Ero preparato perché nessuno
dicesse qualcosa: pazienza.
La cosa bella non è
tanto cosa è un Aardvark,
che è un mammifero subsahariano.
La cosa bella è questa:
che quando vi ho detto Aardvark,
tutti voi avete guardato
questa porzione dell'immagine
senza che vi dicessi alcunché.
Perché?
Perché avete riconosciuto
delle orecchie, degli occhi;
insomma, avete riconosciuto
tutti i tratti tipici
con cui un mammifero
si differenzia dal proprio sfondo.
Non solo: dopo un solo esempio,
voi siete in grado di capire
che altre foto di Aardvark,
con diversa inclinazione
e diversa, in qualche modo, inquadratura
sono Aardvark
e cosa invece è superficialmente simile,
come un formichiere, non lo è.
Un solo esempio!
Quando una rete neurale,
una scatola magica,
vede per la prima volta un Aardvark,
non sa dove guardare.
Tutte le porzioni dell'immagine
possono potenzialmente
contenere un Aardvark.
È questo il motivo profondo
per cui dovete fargliene
vedere dieci milioni.
Se le fate vedere
dieci milioni di immagini diverse,
dove l'Aardvark è in posizioni diverse,
è girato, con o senza luce,
l'intelligenza artificiale
può finalmente capire
cos'è il mammifero e cos'è lo sfondo.
Se passiamo dall'immagine al linguaggio,
che è il mio campo di studio,
le cose sono ancora peggio.
Questo è un classico task
di analogia lessicale, molto semplice.
Il cane abbaia;
Il gatto, ovviamente, miagola.
Io posso prendere
il mio portatile che sta là,
utilizzare i migliori algoritmi
di intelligenza artificiale conosciuti,
e in circa tre ore,
leggendo l'equivalente
di diecimila volte Guerra e Pace,
riusciamo ad avere un sistema
che risponde a questo quesito.
Ma questo non è l'unico modo
di fare le cose.
Esiste un sistema fisico,
molto costoso - soprattutto in America,
dove vivo - e molto complesso,
che risolve questo problema
in maniera molto più facile.
La cosa incredibile è che alcuni di voi
avranno già questo sistema fisico a casa:
qualcuno di voi ne avrà anche più di uno.
Questo sistema lo chiamiamo,
comunemente, bambino.
E per chi non lo sapesse,
è una versione in scala
di un essere umano.
Il bambino risolve questo task
in circa tre secondi,
una volta che voi, semplicemente,
indicate un gatto e dite "miagola".
Un bambino è così bravo a imparare
che tra i 12 e 18 mesi
impara 75 nuove parole al mese.
Un bambino è così bravo a imparare,
che quando vi cadono
le chiavi della macchina
e dite una parolaccia
il bambino lo imparerà
senza che voi lo vogliate.
(Risate)
Ore? Tre ore, diecimila volte
Guerra e Pace -
Guerra e Pace è lungo,
ragazzi, mi han detto;
tre secondi.
È questo il vero gap
tra l'"intelligenza" artificiale
che abbiamo oggi e la vera intelligenza.
La distanza tra il mondo in cui noi siamo
e il mondo di Billie Joy
è la distanza tra le tre ore
e i tre secondi.
La buona notizia è che possiamo
utilizzare i bambini
per costruire delle macchine migliori,
cercando di carpire un po'
i segreti di questo sistema incredibile.
Questo è un esperimento standard,
in cui abbiamo sottoposto
un bambino di sei mesi
a un piccolo gioco:
c'è una rotaia con un trenino,
come vedete, il treno scende dalla rotaia,
lo schermo giallo si solleva
e in qualche modo si vede un cubo
che sta dietro la rotaia.
Fin qui niente di nuovo:
semplicemente, un trenino che scende.
A questo punto noi inganniamo,
da buoni sperimentatori,
questo bambino di sei mesi
e facciamo esattamente la stessa cosa.
Ma quando lo schermo sale,
dopo che il trenino è passato,
mettiamo il cubo in mezzo alla rotaia.
Ovviamente, se non avessimo
ingannato il bambino,
questo è fisicamente impossibile:
nel nostro mondo, i corpi solidi
non si compenetrano.
Ma il bambino non sa niente di fisica:
il bambino ha sei mesi.
Il bambino, anche se voleste
spiegarglielo, non potrebbe capirlo.
Quindi è interessante capire
cosa succede nella testa di un bambino.
Quando il bambino vede
il mondo possibile, il mondo normale,
il bambino è contento,
come tutti i bambini, immagino,
che vedono un trenino
scorrere su una rotaia.
Quando un bambino vede
un mondo impossibile,
che fisicamente non può accadere,
questo è quello che succede.
(Risate)
Il bambino guarda diversi secondi
il setting sperimentale,
in qualche modo domandandosi
cos'è che nella realtà
tendenzialmente non va bene.
Ma c'è una cosa ancora più interessante:
quando voi prendete il trenino
che si comporta in maniera impossibile,
e lo date al bambino,
il bambino farà questo.
(Risate)
Il bambino, cioè, testerà
la solidità del trenino.
Infatti,
se voi invece che fare questo esperimento
prendete una macchinina
e sempre ingannando il bambino -
è facilissimo ingannare i bambini
di sei mesi, apparentemente -
voi prendete una macchinina,
e fingete che vada verso l'alto,
invece che caschi come la gravità predice,
e la date in mano al bambino.
Sapete cosa fa?
La prende, e la fa cadere dal seggiolone,
per testare che la macchinina
effettivamente risponda
alle leggi di gravità.
Queste sono due differenze fondamentali
tra come costruiamo oggi
l'intelligenza artificiale e i bambini.
La prima è che per imparare in fretta
dobbiamo già sapere qualcosa:
nel caso del bambino,
lui ha già una nozione della fisica
in qualche modo intuitiva nel cervello,
e la usa per imparare.
La seconda è che il bambino non sta fermo,
come una rete neurale,
aspettando che voi gli diate
decine di milioni di immagini di gatti.
Il bambino è come un piccolo scienziato:
utilizza il mondo accanto a sè
per fare degli esperimenti,
e capire un po' come funziona la realtà.
La buona notizia è che, in realtà,
possiamo già usare questi principi
per costruire dei sistemi
che funzionano nella realtà,
e nel nostro piccolo
abbiamo incominciato a farlo.
Prendiamo un caso molto semplice,
con cui tutti voi sarete,
immagino, familiari:
comprare vestiti online.
Andate su un e-commerce,
scrivete una parola, "tubino",
e premete Invio.
Quello che succede dall'altra parte
è che c'è un'intelligenza artificiale
che in qualche modo deve provare a capire
il significato di questa nuova parola.
Come facciamo a programmare
un'intelligenza artificiale
che risolva questo problema?
Beh, dobbiamo fare come,
abbiamo visto, fanno i bambini.
La prima cosa che dobbiamo dare
all'intelligenza artificiale
sono delle nozioni,
in qualche modo a priori,
che spiegano qual è
il nostro dominio di riferimento.
Non è la fisica, questo è un dominio
un po più mondano, sono i vestiti:
ma è utile che la nostra
intelligenza artificiale
sappia che i vestiti si dividano,
ad esempio, in abiti, gonne, jeans;
e che a loro volta gli abiti
siano fatti di un certo colore,
un certo materiale,
o abbiano invece un certo stile.
Il secondo ingrediente
che abbiamo visto è l'esperimento:
come facciamo a far sperimentare
un motore di ricerca,
un'intelligenza artificiale
che sta sul vostro browser?
Beh, ovviamente usando voi come cavie:
tutte le volte che voi finite su un sito,
che ha una di queste
nuove intelligenze artificiali
che imparano come i bambini,
tutte le volte che voi
cliccate su un prodotto,
quando l'intelligenza artificiale
vi propone i risultati
del motore di ricerca,
voi siete di fatto
l'equivalente metaforico
del tavolino contro cui il bambino
stava schiacciando il trenino.
L'intelligenza artificiale sta usando voi,
e il vostro feedback,
e la vostra intelligenza,
per imparare utilizzando l'ambiente
in maniera molto efficiente.
Quando voi utilizzate le IA
che funzionano in questo modo,
e non nel modo in cui
la maggior parte del mondo, appunto,
sta in qualche modo facendo
in questo momento,
potete imparare che "tubino" e "vestito"
sono di fatto sinonimi,
con solo dieci esempi.
Dieci esempi non sono tre secondi;
però, nel continuum
tra tre ore e tre secondi,
dieci esempi sono un primo passo,
chiaramente, verso la giusta direzione.
Perché questa cosa
dovrebbe interessare tutti,
e non solo le persone che, come me,
stanno cercando una scusa
per stare dall'altra parte del mondo
rispetto ai propri genitori?
Due motivi.
Il primo è pratico:
ci sono tantissimi ambiti
della vostra vita,
ad esempio ambiti coperti dalla privacy,
o ambiti coperti da eventi molto rari,
in cui neanche volendo
potreste mai accumulare
dieci milioni di esempi.
Noi vorremmo utilizzare le macchine,
e tutte le cose che le macchine
sanno fare meglio di noi in questi ambiti.
Quindi imparare con dieci esempi
è un ottimo modo per poterle
utilizzare in modo più vasto.
Il secondo motivo, forse ancora
più importante, è il sociale.
In mondo in cui i benefici
dell'intelligenza artificiale
delle macchine,
sono appannaggio di company, di aziende
che possono raccogliere milioni, miliardi,
centinaia di miliardi di dati,
è un mondo in cui pochissime company
comandano fondamentalmente il progresso.
Un mondo in cui
la nostra visione del futuro
è fondamentalmente delegata
a quelli che se lo possono permettere.
Ecco: programmare macchine
che funzionino un po' più come i bambini,
in qualche modo democratizza
l'accesso a tutte le nuove tecnologie
e a tutto quello che di buono
noi e le macchine insieme possiamo fare.
L'intelligenza artificiale ha fatto
una serie di progressi spaventosi,
negli ultimi dieci anni,
e non saremo certamente noi a negarlo.
Però, l'intelligenza artificiale vera,
l'unico modo per produrla
è ispirarsi all'unica vera intelligenza
che noi abbiamo a nostra disposizione,
che è quella degli esseri umani
e in particolare, quella dei bambini.
Insomma, possiamo proprio dire,
con buona pace di Bill Joy,
che in realtà il futuro non ha mai avuto
così tanto bisogno di noi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)